Einen hab ich noch.
Ich wollte auch noch was. Aber ganz schnell, wir müssen dann erst in die Warte warten. Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Hallo und guten Abend, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Mit dem Studio sind vom Chaos Computer Club von rechts nach links Frank Rieger. Wir haben ja nur vier Leute, aber nur ein Mikrofon weniger. Trabst?
Hallo.
Nibbler?
Schnaabend.
Und Erdgeist?
Hallo.
Und es geht heute um einen kleinen Jahresrückausdurchblick, was den ganzen Netz-Digital-Computer-Kram angeht. Wir haben angefangen mit Snowden, wir sind dann übergegangen zu was für Nachfolgen das in unserer Gesellschaft bei uns, normalen Leuten, den ich jetzt mal hinterlassen hat, wie die Politik damit umgeht. Nicht so richtig, haben wir gelernt. Und sind jetzt so ein bisschen bei den anderen netzpolitischen Digitalthemen, die dem großen Koalitionsvertrag steht, weil man jetzt vielleicht mal davon ausgehen kann, dass das möglicherweise die Richtung ist, die es in Zukunft so gehen wird. Ich merke gerade, wie ich mir während der ganzen Sendung die Zunge zerbreche, so ein Wort zu finden, was diesen ganzen Themenkomplex umschreibt. Würdet ihr schon Netzpolitik sagen?
Ich würde sagen Schockwellen reiten.
Naja, ich bevorzuge neuerdings eher den Begriff Digital- oder Technologiepolitik.
Digital- oder Technologiepolitik. Da würde ich jetzt einen kleinen Ausflug machen wollen aus dieser Digital- und Technologiepolitik, also durchaus sozusagen in diesem Bereich bleiben wollen, aber weg vom reinen Internet. Zu einem ganz speziellen Fall, nämlich Matthias auch vom Club. Den haben wir jetzt am Telefon. Der hat etwas zu erzählen über eine Sache, die auch in einem großen Koalitionsvertrag vorkommt, wie ich es richtig verstanden habe, nämlich sogenannte Smart Meter. Hallo und guten Abend, Matthias. So, es geht um, man hat dieses Schlagwort vielleicht mal gehört, intelligente Stromzähler. Kannst du uns erst mal erklären, was das ist?
Das hat nichts mit Intelligenz zu tun, muss man als erstes sagen. Das sind einfach elektronische Geräte, die diesen schwarzen Kasten bei dir im Keller ersetzen. Das heißt, da läuft dir immer so eine Scheibe rund, wenn du Strom verbrauchst. Das mechanische Verfahren, was in diesen schwarzen Kisten drin ist, wird jetzt durch Elektronik ersetzt, um nichts anderes geht's.
Aber das hört sich ja erst mal nicht so schlimm an. Können die denn noch irgendwie was mehr, außer zu vermessen, wie viel Kilowattstunden ich verbrauche?
Kommt drauf an, was du für einen Stromverbraucher bist. Also es ist im Prinzip ein Prozess, der seit vier Jahren andauert. Es gibt da Diskussionen, wie man jetzt unser Energiesystem umbauen kann, um die fluktuierende Produktion von erneuerbaren Energien mit besser einzubinden. Was weiß ich, du hast halt viel Strom, wenn der Wind bläst. Oder du hast viel Strom, wenn die Sonne scheint, eben durch Windkraft und Photovoltaik. Und jetzt ist so der Grundgedanke an diesen Smartmetern, okay, man versucht halt Verbrauch dort stattfinden zu lassen, wenn halt sowieso viel Strom im Netz ist. Sprich, du wächst deine Wäsche, wenn deine Photovoltaikanlage auf deinem Dach Strom produziert. Wenn du jetzt ein ganz normaler Mieter bist, dann ändert sich für dich, basierend auf dem, was im Moment diskutiert wird, nicht viel. Du kriegst einfach statt dem schwarzen Kasten einen grauen Kasten und der ist jetzt halt elektronisch. Vielleicht kriegst du auch noch in deiner Wohnung ein kleines Display direkt neben die Haustür, wo draufsteht, was du gerade an Strom verbrauchst.
Föhnen sie jetzt ihre Haare, ist es günstig. Föhnen sie jetzt ihre Haare, ist es günstig. Genau. Das Problem ist ja nur, das gibt ja noch quasi keinerlei Geräte, die auf so eine Steuersignale sindvoll reagieren können.
Das kommt noch hinzu, die ganzen Gerätehersteller sagen halt so, ja im Prinzip können wir das schon machen, aber solange es keinen Standard gibt, machen wir gar nichts.
Also halt, also das ist das Ziel hinter diesen sogenannten intelligenten Stromzählern, dass die deinem Gerät sagen können, so jetzt springen an, weil jetzt ist gerade viel Strom da.
Das ist eins der Ziele, ja.
Okay, jetzt ist es ja so, dass die, dass man immer hört, dass Datenschützer irgendwie diese Geräte nicht so geil finden. Aus welchem Grund das denn?
Genau, bis jetzt haben wir im Prinzip nur von einfachen Systemen, sogenannte intelligente Zähler gesprochen. Es gibt noch intelligente Messsysteme. Die haben Kommunikationsmodule, kommunizieren irgendwie deinen Stromverbrauch alle 15 Minuten zu einem sogenannten Smart Meter Gateway Administrator. Das ist einfach ein Unternehmen, was ein Daten-Filo betreibt. Das heißt, die sammeln alle deine Daten, speichern die und machen die auch für Dritte zugänglich. Zum Beispiel für deinen Stromanbieter. Allerdings kann es dir auch passieren, dass werbetreibende auf diese Daten Zugriff erhalten. Auch das ist im Gespräch. Zu diesen Stromdaten muss man halt sagen, die sind eigentlich sehr sensibel, denn man sieht relativ genau, wenn du elektrisch heiß Wasser machst, wann du duschst, man sieht, wann du zu Hause bist, man sieht, wie oft du deine Wäsche wäschst, man sieht, was dein Kühlschrank so treibt. Das sind Daten, auf die man gucken kann. Und wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, sieht man sehr viel über den Lebensrhythmus, der in dieser Wohnung stattfindet.
Wie oft man Besuch hat, wie oft man für andere Leute kocht, etc. Da kann man echt viel zu viel reininterpretieren.
Und was für Geräte man überhaupt bei sich zu Hause rumstehen hat?
Ob man Schicht arbeitet, ob man überhaupt arbeitet.
Und jetzt, also es gibt dieses Ding, das habe ich verstanden. Es ist auch klar, warum das möglicherweise problematisch ist. Aber was hat jetzt mit dem Koalitionsvertrag zu tun?
Na die große Koalition hat sich jetzt darauf geeinigt, die Rahmenbedingungen für die Einführung von Smartmetern festzulegen und das auch relativ zügig. Es ist dafür jetzt eigentlich kein neues Gesetz erforderlich. Die ganzen Gesetze haben wir schon. Das wurde nur bis jetzt nur durchgeführt. Wenn ich das richtig interpretiere, wirken sie jetzt darauf hin, die entsprechenden Verordnungen zu erlasse und dann soll es mit dem Rollout, also mit der Einführung von dieser Technik einfach losgehen.
Heißt das, dass da Regelungen geschaffen worden sind, wie man diese Teile benutzt oder dass wir die benutzen müssen in Zukunft?
Dass die benutzt werden müssen. Es gibt kein Opt-out. Du kannst nicht sagen, nö will ich nicht. Und wenn man dir zum Beispiel bald eine Photovoltaikanlage hat, also du speist Strom ein, wenn man dir sagt, hier du bekommst so ein kommunizierendes System und wir speichern die Daten, hast du basierend auf dem, was im Moment in der Diskussion ist, keine Möglichkeit zu sagen, ne das will ich aber nicht.
Mal abgesehen von dem Datenschutzaspekt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Leute schon, wenn so eine Systeme dann schon mal am Netz hängen und Informationen sammeln und Steuersignale senden, versucht haben, das zu erforschen, nenne ich es mal. Gibt es da schon Erkenntnisse?
Das ist total sicher, das BSI hat nämlich in einem etwa dreijährigen Prozess ein Schutzprofil entwickelt, wo genau definiert ist, was ein Gerät leisten muss, welche Zugänge es dazu gibt und wie das alles funktioniert. Insofern, also es besteht da keine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung.
Ich behaupte das Gegenteil und ich glaube, da gab es ein Congress Talk dazu letztes Jahr.
Könnte ich die andere Seite auch noch hören?
Die sind bestimmt ganz toll, weil man muss keine Leute mehr einstellen, die die Zähler ablesen gehen.
Also das interessante ist halt, dass auch die Stromversorger haben keinen Bock auf diese Zähler. Die haben ja gerade heute verkündet, dass die sowieso viel zu teuer wären. Und vor allen Dingen haben die ansage Sorge, dass sie ihren Verbrauchern nun Kosten aufdrücken, wo sie sonst irgendwie so schon ein bisschen Strom sparen, hier und da kämpfen. Die sie nie rechtfertigen können. Und wo sie dann sagen müssten, na ja, wir haben hier jetzt irgendwie eine gesetzliche Auflage. Also ich erwarte, dass an der Stelle weiter gestalt wird. Also dass die, also gerade die Stadtwerke, so die kleineren Versorger, die fahren gerade so ein bisschen die Politik, dass sie die Zähler halt einfach nicht abnehmen. Und da haben sie einen guten Grund zu. Insbesondere halt auch aus Sicherheitsgründen, weil so eines der lustigen Probleme ist zum Beispiel, dass in diesen Zählern stecken häufiger mal GSM Modems drinnen oder es werden Systeme benutzt, um über die Stromlettung selbst die Datenübertragung zu machen. Und in so einem Smart Meter steckt halt schon eine ganze Menge Elektronik drin und da sind dann halt gerne mal öfter mal so ein halbes Gigabyte Firmware drin, die dann halt auch mal geupdatet werden muss, wenn halt ein Sicherheitsproblem entsteht. Weil man zum Beispiel mit so einem Smart Meter der neuen Generation auch eine Anschlussabschaltung machen kann, wenn mal der Nutzer mal wieder seine Rechnung nicht bezahlt hat. Und wenn man halt nun die Kombination von wir haben da Smart Meter da draußen, millionenfach, die nicht wirklich updatebar sind, weil man irgendwie einen viel zu schmal bannigen Datenkanal dahin hat, mit wir haben ein halbes Gigabyte Firmware, die sicherlich angreifbar ist und man kann damit Stromanschlüsse abschalten, dann haben wir Blinken-Lights.
Oder in Kombination mit einer kaputten DPI könnte man dann sogar so weit gehen und einfach den Strom ausschalten durch einen Hack und sagen können, gebe jetzt die Kreditkarte ein, du wirst immer nur auf die gleiche Seite geleitet und erst dann kriegst du wieder Strom, bis du, ja wohl das funktioniert nicht, wenn es keinen Strom gibt für das Ding Snowden. Aber sowas in die Richtung.
Dein Strom geht in 30 Minuten aus, wenn du eine Kreditkartendaten fängst.
Genau, du zahlst jetzt 500 Euro per Paypal, aber wir knipsen den Strom aus.
Und wir blinken schon zweimal, um dir zu beweisen, dass wir es ernst meinen.
Du weißt, dass es da noch so ein Paper gab, dass sich das schon alles rentiert, in dem Moment, wo man anfängt, seine Nutzerdaten zu verkaufen.
Ich glaube, in der Datenschleuder gab es da auch mal von irgend weis grad nicht mehr wem, einen Artikel zu den Smart Mietern zum Nachlesen. Gut, gut.
Ja, der war von mir.
Matthias, du hast dich mit dem Thema ernsthafter beschäftigt. Was glaubst du denn, was jetzt passieren wird? Werden die kommen oder wird das sozusagen so im Sande verlaufen, weil eigentlich keiner drauf Bock hat?
Es ist ehrlich gesagt schwierig. Also die kleinen Stadtwerke oder auch größere Stadtwerke, die überhaupt keine Lust auf die Technik haben, versuchen eigentlich schon seit vier Jahren mit Händen und Füßen die Dinger nicht einzubauen, obwohl sie es eigentlich müssten. Jetzt gehen ihnen halt juristisch die Argumente aus. Wer davon profitiert, sind die größeren Stromanbieter und Telekommunikationsanbieter in Deutschland, die entsprechend in den letzten zwei Jahren auch sehr rege an diesem Standardisierungsprozess mitgewirkt haben. Das heißt, es ist im Moment so eine unentschiedene Situation. Ich bin mir nicht ganz darüber im Klaren, was jetzt passieren wird.
Das werden wir also im Auge behalten. Matthias, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für diesen Bericht über die Smart Meter.
Ich danke.
Bis dann, tschüss. So, und wir haben gleich auch noch einen Punkt, der im Prinzip zur selben Kategorie zählt, nämlich Technik, die eigentlich relativ eng in unserem ganz privaten Lebensbereich, also in unserem Haus ist, die aber nicht mal unserer Kontrolle unterliegt. Das ist der Routerzwang. Also Router ist ja für die meisten von uns einfach das Gerät, was man irgendwie mitgeliefert kriegt oder sich selber kauft. Wenn man Internetanschluss an den Start bringt, das macht halt irgendwie WLAN, versorgt die Telefone und kümmert sich überhaupt darum, dass das Internet zu Hause funktioniert. Was verbindet sich hinter dem Wort Routerzwang?
Also mit dem Wort Routerzwang ist gemeint, dass du, wenn man sich eine DSL-Leitung nach Hause holt, der Provider unbedingt das DSL-Modell vom Provider mit dem roten oder magenten Label einem aufzwingt und man hat keine Macht, was anderes Eigenes dorthin zu stellen, was unter seiner Kontrolle ist.
Inklusive der Möglichkeit, dass der Provider selbst die Firmware in diesem Gerät updatet. Du dich da auch nicht so wirklich drauf einloggen kannst, du auch deine Zugangsdaten nicht bekommst, sondern dein Internet fängt nicht an deiner Telefonnose an, sondern dein Internet fängt an den Ports deines Routers an. Also die Grenze zwischen dir und dem Provider verschiebt sich um ein Gerät weiter in deine Richtung.
Das hört sich ja total komfortabel an, weil ich muss mich da noch nichts mehr kümmern.
Einerseits sehr komfortabel, aber andererseits kann man einfach, wenn man jetzt, man könnte zum Beispiel auch sagen, du hast da vier Anschlüsse dran und für jeden Anschluss musst du zwei Euro mehr zahlen. Oder wenn du mehr als zwei Geräte dahinter anschließen willst, musst du auch mehr zahlen.
Oder wenn du noch ISDN-Nummern von irgendwo draufschalten möchtest, von wem anders, kannst du nicht mehr deinen eigenen Voice-over-IP-Endpunkt benutzen, sondern musst den des Anbieters benutzen.
Genau, du wirst einfach dazu gezwungen, Services oder Möglichkeiten zu nutzen, die dir dein Anbieter anbietet, auch wenn die technischen Möglichkeiten des Gerätes weit drüber sind. Und du kannst deutlich mehr damit machen, aber dein Anbieter verbietet es dir einfach, weil das kann.
Also in der Praxis bedeutet das, dass wir einfach ein weiteres Gerät mehr im Haus rumstehen haben, weil wenn man dann diese Dinge nutzen möchte, muss man sich halt noch einen Router kaufen, mit dem man vor seinen Router hängt.
Na toll. Und wenn man Pech hat, darüber noch eine VPN-Verbindung dann nach Schweden aufbauen, um da wieder richtiges Internet zu bekommen. Also da kommt dann nicht mehr wirklich Internet aus der Wand, sondern irgendwie kastriertes Web oder Schlandnet oder...
Dazu kommen wir auch gleich noch. Zum Schlandnet aber, dieser Rotazwang, der steht jetzt auch in diesem Koalitionsvertrag drin.
Genau, der steht jetzt auch drin. Ich muss mal ein bisschen runterscrollen, dann seh ich so viel den Abschnitt. Aber ja, sie fordern das halt, dass man halt... Also zum Beispiel, wenn der Kunde jetzt sagen möchte, du kriegst einen fertigen Router geschippt und er hat es alles eingegeben, du musst nur noch anschließen und er tut. Aber zum Beispiel kriegst du ja nicht mehr die Zugangsdaten oder die Möglichkeit, deine eigene DSL-Einwahl zu machen mit deinem eigenen Router, das geht teilweise nicht mehr. Und das wollen sie halt zurückfordern, dass man halt wirklich sagt, wenn es technisch möglich ist und geht wie zum Beispiel bei DSL, dass der Kunde sich einen eigenen Router holt, den er hinschleppselt, dann muss er diese Möglichkeit auch bekommen.
Aha, also das ist ja neben der Netzneutralität, klingt das erstmal positiv?
Das macht halt einen begrenzt Sinn. Also bei DSL kann man das halt machen, wo ich jetzt andere Anschlusstechnologien kenne, wo das jetzt eher eine schlechte Idee ist, dass da Hins und Kunst sein Router anschließt aus dem Media Markt und dann da einfach mal mitmacht.
Ach, das ist die Telekom-Argumentation, die damals uns verboten hat, unsere eigenen Modems an, an die Telefonleitung zu schließen, weil ihnen da mal so ein Vermittlungszentrum abgebrannt ist, weil jemand da irgendwie 220 Volt auf die Amtsstromleitung draufgeschaltet hat.
Theoretisch ist das die ähnliche Sache. Nur wenn du heutzutage deine DSL-Leitung kaputt machst, weil du einen Kurzschluss machst, dann ist das dein Problem. Aber wenn du ein kaputt konfiguriertes Kabelmodem hast und dann hast du auf diesem Kupferdraht nicht nur dich und die Gegenseite, sondern auch 200-300 andere Kunden und die müssen alle mitleiden, dadurch dass du nicht in der Lage bist, oder so blöd bist, deinen Router zu konfigurieren, oder einfach böswillig.
Oder du einfach einen Router kaufst, der nicht so toll ist, sondern...
Genau, der einfach mal sagt, ich nehme das nicht so genau und nehme halt 5 Mhz oben drüber und unten drunter auch noch dazu.
Das Ganze geht noch weiter, weil in Zukunft sollten wir wirklich sowas wie Glasfasern zu Hause bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist, oder ob es da schon was Neues gibt. Passive optische Netze, G-Porn, da hängen im Prinzip auch mehrere Leute an einer Faser dran. Da möchte man auch nur das Equipment dran hängen haben als Provider, was dafür geeignet ist.
Genau, also Chaos Computer Club ist für guter Zwang.
Nein, also nicht überhaupt.
Also ich denke mal, dass uns die Geschichte uns gelehrt hat, als die Telekom uns nur die amtlich zugelassenen Telefone und zwar genau nur ihr es erlaubt hat, hatten wir eine garstige Zeit. Und erst die einigermaßen flauschige Deregulierung danach hat dann gemacht, dass da es wurden Standards geschaffen. Alle mussten sich an diese Standards halten. Und wenn man heute in den Mediamarkt geht, dann bekommt man auch üblicherweise Modems und Fritz-Boxen und Kram, die alle diesen Standard sprechen und die nicht die Vermittlungsstellen abfackeln.
Ja, was bei Telekom Technologie, also DSL in dem Fall ist, es gibt da halt andere Technologien, du hast halt genau falsch gesagt. Eigentlich, ich bin jetzt auch nicht dagegen, ich bin auch nicht dafür, aber man muss den Mittelweg finden. Weil bei Kabel macht es halt keinen Sinn, weil da gibt es halt keine Zugangsdaten, so grob gesagt.
Also ich glaube, meine Ansagen sind immer Modems und so weiter.
Also da würde es einfach schon helfen, wenn es keinen Routerzwang gibt, aber eben eine Liste vom Provider, verwende mal diese Geräte und wenn du diese Geräte nicht verwendest, dann kriegst du im Zweifel auf den Deckel und dann Anschluss abgestellt.
Oder man sagt, man stellt ein maximal transparentes Gerät in die Mitte, was bei DSL ein Splitter ist, den man bekommt, oder ein ganz dummes Kabelmodem, wo man dann seine Fritzbox, seinen Router, seine High-Secure OpenBSD Harden Kernel selbstgebaute Lösungen dran bauen kann. Also einfach nur, damit man dem User wieder alle Möglichkeiten gibt, die er hat, die technisch Sinn machen.
Ich weiß nicht. Also ich bin der Meinung, also die Post hat ja damals wenigstens noch den Anstand gehabt, zu dem Telefonwasser einen ins Haus gestellt haben, den Strom selber mitzuliefern. Da kam Amtsstrom und dann konnte man das Telefon benutzen, egal ob man selber da noch Strom rangehalten hat oder nicht. Heutzutage wird einem so ein Kasten reingestellt und ich sage immer, wenn ich den Strom für den Scheiß bezahle, dann will ich auch die komplette Kontrolle darüber haben. Das ist auch genau mit den Smartmetern. Ich hätte noch fragen sollen, wie die Smartmeter eigentlich betrieben werden, ob man den Strom dafür oder selber bezahlen muss.
Stimmt, interessante Sache.
Das Netz dahin hängt bestimmt hinter dem Zähler.
So, jetzt fiel gerade schon mal der Begriff und wir verlassen damit, glaube ich, auch den Koalitionsvertrag. Aber es hat trotzdem was mit dem Thema heute zu tun, nämlich es ist eine Konsequenz aus den Dingen, die passiert sind, dass in der letzten Zeit, zumindest im Netz, in meiner Teilenbein, tauchte dieser Begriff häufiger auf Schlantnet. Was ist das Schlantnet und wofür brauchen wir das?
Also das ist eine Idee von Politikern, was eigentlich schon alles aussagt, aber...
Die drei Wochen diskreditiert.
Die Idee ist halt, man baut ein Internet mit deutschen Grenzen. Und ich betone das jetzt nicht absichtlich anders, aber es wird die von Deutschland.
Wenn die bösen US-Amerikaner unsere Leitungen und Pakete abschneucheln, dann machen wir das halt so, dass das Internet nur in Deutschland und da haben wir dann völlig unsere Hoheit drüber. Oder meinetwegen im Schengen-Raum.
Das heißt, die Daten, die wir den amerikanischen Geheimdiensten über Google-Mail oder Dropbox oder Facebook oder über Swift oder über die Fluggastdatumwettergabe, dann in die Hand drücken, machen wir wenigstens übergeschützte Leitungen. Damit nicht sonst...
Ich glaube, du müsstest jetzt, also das war schon sehr sarkastisch und ich glaube, wenn man wusste, wovon du redest, musste man auch lachen, aber jetzt musst du es nochmal genau erklären. Diese ganzen Sachen, die du gerade gesagt hast, was ist das? Was hat das dann gesagt?
Also grundsätzlich haben wir das Problem, dass wir eh schon freiwillig alle möglichen Daten von uns im Privaten, aber auch politisch gewollt institutionalisiert in die USA in dort in Jurisdiktion übergeben. Zum Beispiel indem wir Daten bei Dropbox hochladen, indem wir Informationen über uns bei Facebook eintippern, indem wir oder indem unsere gewählten Vertreter die Flugastdaten dann für die amerikanischen Geheimdienste zum Auswerten aufbereiten und diese Informationen werden eh schon den Geheimdiensten, gegen die wir uns hier angeblich schützen wollen, auf dem Silbertablett präsentiert. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt anfangen, ein Schland- oder Schengen-Netz zu bauen, dann schützen wir eigentlich die Daten nur so in unserem kleinen Teich erstmal vor einem unklaren Angreifer, um sie dann am Ende dann doch dem Geheimdienste, dem wir uns angeblich gegenüber schützen wollen, in die Hand zu drücken.
Ja, aber wir haben dann diese Daten als Verhandlungsmassen können sagen, ha ha, wir geben euch diese Daten nicht, wenn... Na gut, also... ihr nicht ganz lieb bitte sagt. Es gibt ja natürlich schon durchaus Argumente, die dafür sprechen, dass man zumindest nicht leichtfertig Daten mit den Amerikanern und den Briten ausliefert, die man ihnen nicht ausliefern muss. Na alle.
Na alle sollte man ihnen nicht ausliefern wollen.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn wir auf einen Server in den USA wollen, und die nicht in der Lage sind, die Verbindung zu verschlüsseln, dann... Das Bizarre ist ja, dass es diese Landesgrenzen im Internet einfach prinzipbedingt nicht gibt. Also du kannst auch auf einen Google-Server Daten hochladen und der steht in Deutschland. So, das ist für den Benutzer völlig transparent, wo dieser Server steht.
Aber was ist denn die Idee in dem Zustand jetzt, wie soll das auch funktionieren?
Die Idee dabei ist halt einfach zu sagen, wenn die Route der Daten von einem Nutzer innerhalb Deutschlands oder innerhalb der EU zu einem anderen Nutzer innerhalb Deutschlands oder der EU geht, dann sollen die Daten nicht unbedingt über den großen Teich geroutet werden oder nicht unbedingt über Großbritannien geroutet werden. Dafür gibt es ein kleines Top-Set von Nutzungen und Services, für die es möglicherweise sogar sinn machen könnte. Zum Beispiel bei Sova-EPI. Allein schon wegen der Latenz. Es ist schon grundsätzlich ein sinnvolles Ding, dass man Daten möglichst lokal hält. Genau. Das Problem ist nur, dass diejenigen, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass es eben nicht so ist, dass die Daten möglichst lokal geroutet werden, sind halt ausgerechnet die Telekom. Ich hatte neulich die Gelegenheit, mich mit deren Chef zu streiten. Es kommt morgen in der FAZ, das Stratgespräch, genau über dieses Thema Deutschlandnet oder Schengennet oder wie auch immer man es nennen möchte. Es gibt tatsächlich ein interessantes Argument dabei, was diesen ganzen Dingen einen gewissen Charme verleiht. Und zwar der BND hat ja, wie wir jetzt aus Reportagen wissen, darauf bestanden, dass eigentlich alles, was ins Internet geht, internationaler Verkehr ist. Also auch wenn es eigentlich deutscher Verkehr ist. Sie filtern halt nur E-Mail-Adressen mit DE-Domains raus als einziges Unterteilungs-Kriterium, was natürlich völliger Bullshit ist. Wenn man jetzt aber sagt, okay, wir haben also eine technische, unrechtliche Lösung, die dafür sorgt, dass deutsche Bits in Deutschland bleiben, dann müsste der BND sich ja da zurückziehen, weil wir technisch dafür gesorgt haben, dass da gar keine Bits lang kommen können, für die er sich beruflich interessieren sollte. Das ist aber auch ungefähr das einzige Argument, was mir irgendwie eingefallen ist für diese Deutschland-Net oder Schengen-Net-Geschichte. Weil natürlich ist eines der Probleme, dass selbst wenn die Daten magischerweise im europäischen Raum bleiben und nicht von britischen oder amerikanischen Dienstleistern geroutet werden, also wo Leute da hin gehen, wie zum Beispiel auf Google-Server in Deutschland stehen und trotzdem Google gehören und unterliegen, dann ist immer noch das Problem, dass zum Beispiel im Schengen-Raum die Dänen und die Franzosen und die Holländer und andere Leute ihre Geheimdienste haben, die ganz selbstverständlich mit schnorcheln und ihre Daten mit den Amerikanern und den Briten teilen. Also diese ganze Idee ist halt mehr so, naja, wir müssen doch jetzt mal irgendwas tun, irgendeine Idee muss doch jemand mal haben, um diesem ganzen Problem so ein bisschen hart zu werden. Und so ist halt so ein bisschen so eher der Gedanke dabei.
Jetzt also das Schlandnetz ist, ich fasse das mal zusammen, was von euch gerade da oben sind. Jetzt gibt es auch die Idee, der Schland klaut, könnte man quasi sagen. Also im Rahmen dieses so ja, die großen Dienste, die halt alle total gerne benutzen, die sind halt, die sitzen meistens in den USA. Was ist halt schwierig, jetzt gibt es die Idee, ja, das ist doch eine Chance für die deutsche Internetindustrie, dass sie jetzt sozusagen Dienste anbieten kann.
Wir wollen einen offenen Teil vom Kuchen mit den Daten haben.
Es funktioniert halt noch nicht, weil alles, was die Amis gerade bauen, also die ganzen Start-ups, die...
Funktioniert schon, man muss das nur auf solide Beine stellen. Wenn daraus wirklich eine Förderung von kleinen innovativen Unternehmen und von Open Source, Kropto und dergleichen wird.
Man kann sowas wie Dropbox auch bauen in Open Source, mit kryptographisch gesichert, mit distributed. Muss man ein bisschen Geld drauf werfen, muss ja Leute, kleinere Firmen, sich darum balgen lassen um so einen Kuchen und das nicht an keine Ahnung T-Systems oder die üblichen Verdächtigen vergeben, sondern einfach wie die Amis das da gemacht haben im Silicon Valley, einfach mal ein bisschen Geld mit der Gießkanne darüber streuen lassen, aber wieder auf achten, dass es kleine Firmen sind. Kann man so auch...
Ja, da ist dann halt ein Konflikt mit Lobbyismus und sonst was, weil die Kleinen kriegen seltenst die Chance und am Ende ist halt einfach der Punkt, weil die Leute hören und kennen Dropbox, also benutzen sie Dropbox, weil sie googeln nach Dropbox und wenn da nicht in Deutschland was anderes auftaucht, dann benutzen sie halt den Service und machen sich halt selten Gedanken dazu, wo das jetzt herkommt, weil man kann jetzt halt auch, es gibt schon Dropbox Service, die halt in Deutschland gehostet werden, nur sie benutzt keiner, weil man findet sie nicht oder andere Sachen sind halt einfach besser erreichbar.
Aber es ist tatsächlich eine grundlegende Frage, also nicht irgendwelches Aus ist nur hier zu haben, sondern gezielt Softwareentwicklung, User-Interfaces Entwicklung und so weiter. Das ist alles Zeug, wo Leute, wenn sie es nebenbei machen, ja, kommt was bei rum, aber wenn man das wirklich professionell fördert und sagt, okay, wir haben als EU das Ziel, dass wir unseren Bürgern Tools an die Hand geben wollen. Ja, wir fördern Open Source Softwareentwicklung über das übliche hinaus, dass sich Leute wirklich mal die Zeit nehmen können, was zu bauen, was dann Hand und Fuß hat, was ein cooles User-Interface hat, was bedienbar ist, was benutzbar ist.
Ja, da fangen sie ja jetzt an. Also Freifunk kriegt jetzt, glaube ich, vom MABB Förderung genau um, halt ein dezentrales Netz aufzubauen. Und so langsam wird das halt öfters mal gemacht mit anderen Projekten. Aber sobald dann halt, wenn es um sowas wie eine Berlin City Cloud oder sonst was wieder das Ding hieß, was ich letztes gelesen habe. Und dann liest du da, dass es von IBM und Siemens betrieben wird.
Aber noch mal eine andere Idee zu sagen. Also hier geht es ja darum, dass die Firma da nicht in den USA sitzt, sondern es ist halt immer noch eine zu große Firma, wie ihr auch sagt. Aber wäre es nicht auch sozusagen noch eine Strategie, dass diese Cloud, die ja letztendlich auch nur irgendwo Rechenkraft ist, also ein Rechner, dass die zu den in die Wohnung der Leute wandert? Also ich habe es jetzt selber mal ausprobiert und habe sagen, so einen kleinen Custom-Mail mit am Schreibtisch stehen, der für mich die Cloud ist, der auch schneller ist als die Dropbox.
Na ja, was benutzt du denn da? Welche Technologie darunter benutzt du denn? Das ist ja schon genau der Weg. Du hast da dann einen BitTorrent Sync-Client, der irgendwie auch dieses BitTorrent-Protokoll, wo die Leute eh schon vertraut mit sind, benutzt, um die Daten auszutauschen. Und wenn man die Idee noch ein bisschen zu Ende denkt, dann kann jeder sich hier zu Hause auf seinem PC diese Software installieren, oder meinetwegen sogar auf seinem Router, und hat dann eine distributierte Deutschland-Cloud, in der er kryptografisch gesichert die Daten hingepackt werden. Kann man ja von ausgehen.
Aber haltet ihr das sozusagen für was ersträbenswert ist, was man vielleicht vorwärtsbringen soll?
Das ist so eins der großen Mangos, was wir gerade haben, was wir vorhin auch erzählt haben. Irgendjemand, der ein bisschen größere Mengen von Dateien austauschen möchte mit einem Kollegen oder so, hat halt das Problem, dass außer in Dropboxen nirgendwo so richtig bequem funktioniert.
Na ja, es scheitert halt einfach daran, dass die Software, die verfügbar ist, entweder enterprise ist und sofort ausführbar und extrem viel Lizenzasche nimmt. Und die andere Lösung ist zwar auch toll, open source, aber halt naja, sie ist halt für Nerds designt und nicht von einem Interface Designer, der sich auch mal damit beschäftigt hat, wie eine normale Bürokraft irgendwie sowas benutzt. Und daran scheitert es dann halt. Dann ist halt doch wieder am Ende das Dropbox, weil das integriert sich ja in den Windows Explorer.
Das hat das alte Problem von Open Source Software, wenn das irgendwelche Hacker in ihrer Freizeit nebenbei machen, dann machen sie es für sich selbst, wenn sie die Ressourcen, die Kohle und die Zeit vor allem dafür haben, das mal mit viel Ruhe für Benutzer zu machen, sich mit den Ansprüchen der Benutzer ein bisschen auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja, vor allem die Ressourcen mit Leuten, die sowas... Also wenn man halt eine Firma baut, dann macht man sich halt bisschen mehr Gedanken über, dass man sein Geld wieder reinbekommt und dann investiert man halt auch Geld da rein, dass man da einen Interface Designer anstellt.
Was muss man tun, damit die Nutzer das toll finden und nutzen und alles Schönes?
Ja, und das dann wieder halt was genau zugeschnitten auf genau eine Person oder auf einen Personenkreis passt, aber nicht für die Masse kompatibel ist und an so Sachen scheitert es dann halt immer.
Aber vielleicht klappt es ja doch noch. Wir sind jetzt von Snowden über den großen Koalitionsvertrag in die Cloud, dort unter unserem Schreibtisch und jetzt erst mal zu den Nachrichten, Bilder und Verkehr und danach vielleicht noch eine halbe Stunde hier Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Mal live und an Plakt hören wollt? Dann haben wir genau das für euch.
Fritz präsentiert.
Montag, 20.
Januar. Live im Heimathafen Neukölln.
Royal Republic auf Akustiktour.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Die SPD hat ihre Werbetour für den Koalitionsvertrag mit der Union begonnen. Auf einer Regionalkonferenz in Hofheim bei Frankfurter Main lobte Parteichef Gabriel die Vereinbarung. Der Koalitionsvertrag sei eindeutig von der Handschrift der SPD geprägt. Gabriel betronte vor allem die Erfolge in der Renten- und Arbeitsmarktpolitik, wie die geplante Einführung eines flächendeckenden Mindestlohns. Zum ersten Mal entscheidet die Partei Basis, ob die Sozialdemokraten eine große Koalition eingehen. Das Ergebnis der Mitgliederbefragung soll am 14. Dezember feststehen. Europa fährt beim Ostpartnerschaftsgipfel in Litauen einen harten Kurs gegenüber der Ukraine. Luxemburgs Premier Juncker forderte in Vilnius, der Fall der inhaftierten Oppositionsführerin Timoschenko müsse gelöst werden. Außerdem müsse der ukrainische Präsident Janukowicz innere Reformen umsetzen. Vor dem Gipfel hatte die Ukraine ein Abkommen mit der EU über einen vertraglichen Zusammenschluss und freien Handel auf Eis gelegt. Bei dem Treffen will die EU ihre Beziehungen zu den sechs früheren Sowjetrepubliken Ukraine, Weißrussland, Armenien, Aserbaidschan, Georgien und Moldau weiter vertiefen. Der Polizei ist ein Schlag gegen ein internationales Netzwerk von Autodieben gelungen. Bei einer Großrazie in Niedersachsen, im Saarland und in Nordrhein-Westfalen nahmen die Fahnder zahlreiche Verdächtige fest. Der Schwerpunkt der Aktion lag im Ruhrgebiet. Die professionell abmeidende Autoschieberbande stahl zum Teil Entschuldigung, jetzt hab ich mich verschluckt. Stahl zum Teil hochwertige Autos, die sie anschließend zerlegte. Einzelteile, wie Motoren, wurden dann ins Ausland verschoben. Ziele waren unter anderem Osteuropa und die Benelux-Staaten. Eintracht Frankfurt hat in der Europa League vorzeitig die K.o.-Runde erreicht. Die Frankfurter gewannen beim französischen Club Giron d'Or-Bordeaux mit 1 zu 0 und sind damit vor dem letzten Spieltag Gruppensieger. Auch der SC Freiburg darf weiter auf den Einzug in die Zwischenrunde hoffen. Die Freiburger gewannen ihr Spiel gegen den tschechischen Vereins Lovan Liberic mit 2 zu 1. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick 6, in Charlottenburg noch 7 Grad, Prenzlau und Wiesenburg melden 5 Grad, Falkensee und Eisenhüttenstadt 6 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist nur locker bewölkt und es bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf plus zwei bis minus ein Grad. Am Tag ist es dann dicht bewölkt und von Westen zieht Regen zu uns, bei maximal 4 bis 6 Grad plus. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A115, Awus Stadt Einwärts. Zwischen dem Parkplatz Dreilinden und Kreuz Zehlendorf sind zwei Spuren und die Ausfahrt gesperrt, da wird die Fahrbahn erneuert. Charlottenburg, der Rohrdamm, ist heute Nacht zwischen Saatwinklerdamm und Nonnendammallee in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, da wird gebaut. Nach Brandenburg, A11 Berlin, Richtung Pomellen, zwischen Warnitz und Gramzow gab es einen Unfall, die rechte Spur ist dort blockiert. Und B101 Mariendorf Trebin, Vorsicht zwischen Ludwigsfelde und Tyro, in beiden Richtungen, da sind nämlich Tiere auf der Fahrbahn unterwegs. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Kostenlos, jetzt in euren Google Play und App Store.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Cars Radio im Blue Moon, Snowden, Snake Oil, Schlangnetz, all die schlimmen Sachen haben wir heute hier besprochen. Zu Gast sind immer noch Erdgeiss, Nibbler, Fraps und Frank. Und wir haben schon besprochen, was war und was es für Auswirkungen hatte und was dann in unserem Koalitionsvertrag steht und was die Leute so planen. Was ist denn eure Idee davon, was im nächsten Jahr uns so beschäftigen würde? Also was ich erstaunlich fand, ist, dass mal abgesehen von dieser ganzen Geheimdienstsache, die halt ziemlich groß ist, aber dass so netzpolitisch scheint es, oder wie heißt es, digitalpolitisch, nicht alles verloren ist, sondern es gibt schon zumindest ein paar Ansätze, die irgendwie wenigstens diskutabel sind.
Na ja, natürlich können auch Regierungspolitiker nicht daran vorbei, dass nun mittlerweile in einem vernetzten Zeitalterleben und digitalen Technologiepolitik in allen Politikbereichen wichtig wird. Und natürlich gibt es ja diese Diskussion darüber, jetzt ein Internetministerium zu schaffen, was ich so ein bisschen merkwürdig halte angesichts der dabei diskutierten Personalien, die da ventiliert wurden.
Von allein?
Ja, von allein wurde gerade ventiliert. Vor einer Weile ging es auch darum, irgendwie den Gutenberg aus dem Abklingbecken zu holen. Also da, naja, sagen wir mal so, ich würde mal denken, das lassen wir mal lieber, bis man da vielleicht irgendwie eine Personalgeneration hat, die möglicherweise auch weiß, was sie da tut. Aber klar, es wird halt, also diese Bereich von Politik wird eben zu einem Bereich von richtiger Politik, das heißt also, wo es halt eben auch konträrere Positionen geben wird, nicht nur, es geht jetzt nicht mehr nur um Verständnis oder Nichtverständnis oder darum, dass wir da blind rein stolpern, was auch noch zur Genüge passiert, sondern eben auch darüber, dass es konträre Positionen gibt und weniger freiheitlich gesinnte Zeitgenossen unter den Politikern eben solche Positionen auch vertreten. Und wir auch damit leben müssen, dass sowas ja durchaus auch eine valide politische Ansicht sein kann, auch wenn sie uns nicht gefällt.
Okay, aber sag mal, man kann jetzt wenigstens diskutieren und muss nicht so sagen, alles ganz von vorne erklären.
An einigen Stellen muss man es ganz von vorne erklären, aber an vielen Stellen sind wir mittlerweile in einen Bereich angekommen, wo man zumindest ein technisches Basisverständnis so ganz grob voraussetzen kann.
Das dort ist eine Maus. Was wird uns denn im nächsten Jahr erwarten?
Hast du Bitcoins?
Ich habe tatsächlich irgendwo, also diese virtuelle Währung, wo wir über ein von einem Jahr oder so glaube ich auch hier im Chaosradio sprachen, ich habe tatsächlich mal von jemandem 0, 00001 Bitcoins in den Wallet überwiesen bekommen, dass ich leider nicht mehr habe.
Jetzt krammen sie alle wieder nach ihren Wollezweidan noch 12, 10 Bitcoins, die eigentlich nichts werden.
Ach ja, ich wollte noch was, ich habe einen USB-Stick verloren mit 300 Bitcoins drauf, irgendwo in der Nähe des der US-Amerikanischen Botschaft, da könnte er vielleicht mal beim Umgraben helfen. Aber ich glaube, der Kay wollte noch wen grüßen.
Genau, ich wollte noch einen Kollegen grüßen, der glaube ich zum heutigen Standpunkt letzte oder vor zwei Wochen eine Pizza bestellt hat, mit Bitcoins bezahlt hat und diese Pizza, Salami oder irgendwas war es im Büro, hat ihn jetzt ungerechnet 80 bis 120 Euro gekostet. Ich weiß nicht mal, ob sie so gut geschmeckt hat.
Jetzt müsst ihr aber noch mal kurz erklären, was das mit den Bitcoins auf sich hat.
Na die Bitcoins ist so eine der ersten wirklich funktionierenden Internet auf Kryptographie und nicht auf den Vertrauen in Banken basierende Geldeinheit. Das funktioniert so, dass viele Leute dran rumrechnen müssen, um zu bestätigen, dass eine bestimmte Zahlung auch wirklich stattgefunden hat und nachdem diese kryptographisch abgesichert bewiesen wurde, bekommen alle, die da mitgerechnet haben, wenn sie Glück haben, auch so ein bisschen was von dieser Einheit wieder ausgezahlt. Das ist das sogenannte Minen und jeder kann da reingucken, dass die da schon ordentlich wirklich Arbeit reingesteckt haben. Man kann sich nicht welche einfach so aus den Fingern saugen und dieses kryptographisch gesicherte Geld ist weltweit verfügbar für jeden, der einen Computer hat und und der Kurs dieser Bitcoins ist in den letzten Wochen und Monaten sprunghaft angestiegen.
Im halben Jahr eigentlich von glaube einem Euro oder zwei rum für ein Bitcoin und jetzt steht er gerade bei 800 Euro und schon über 1000 Dollar. Aber er war ziemlich kurz vorm Scheitern und die Leute haben eigentlich gesagt, macht keinen Sinn mehr. Inzwischen sitzen sie halt da und so, die fünf Euro von damals sind jetzt irgendwie 10.000 Euro.
Ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, Chaosradio 169 am 30.06.2011 war über Bitcoins und damals war so die gängige Meinung, dass auch die Leute, die sich damit auskannten, sagten so, naja, das ist ein sehr interessantes Experiment und das ist total spannend, aber das ist sozusagen ein Schritt in der Entwicklung und der nächste oder die übernächste, der wird dann sozusagen eine richtige virtuelle Währung. Wie ist das gekommen, dass es Bitcoin immer noch gibt?
Also so eine schöne Blase hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr. Na, es gibt ein paar ganz handvolle Gründe dafür. Einer davon ist, dass Bitcoin es ermöglicht, relativ problemlos Geld zwischen Währungen hin und her zu bewegen, was sonst in einigen Ländern, insbesondere China, schwierig ist. China hat ja eine interne und eine externe Währung, den Renminbi und den Yuan, und zwischen denen Geld zu tauschen ist stark reguliert, also kann man nicht ohne weiteres tun. Nun kann man aber auf diversen Börsen sowohl Bitcoins für Yuan kaufen und für Renminbi verkaufen und umgekehrt. Das heißt, da gibt es plötzlich einen Weg mit dieser digitalen Währung, relativ problemlos zwischen diesen beiden regulierten Währungen herzutauschen und so ist es auch in anderen Stellen. Bitcoins sind, was die Beweglichkeit und die Flüssigkeit des Geldes angeht, quasi allen anderen Währungen überlegen, weil man sie tatsächlich auch offline speichern kann. Man ist nicht von einer zentralen Entität abhängig, die irgendwie bei PayPal oder so die Accounts sperren kann. Man muss sich nicht ausweisen. Das ist also quasi alle Vorteile einer digitalen Währung, wie man sie schon immer mal haben wollte. Und dementsprechend wird sie auch an allen möglichen Stellen benutzt, die völlig unerwartet waren. Also wo man nicht dachte, dass es ein Problem gibt, zum Beispiel Geld von A nach B zu bewegen, ist aber solche Probleme gehabt, die wir einfach schlicht nicht kennen, weil es hier meistens kein großes Problem ist. Und wo Leute Bitcoin entdecken und anfangen, es zu benutzen. Ich denke, es gibt ja nicht nur Bitcoin, sondern auch eine Menge andere solcher Währungen. Also die nächstgrößere ist sogenannte Litecoin, die mathematisch ein bisschen anders funktioniert, aber den selben Prinzipien folgt. Diese Währungen werden denke ich mal sehr viel größer und sehr viel umfangreicher werden, als wir das noch so vor einem Jahr oder zwei angenommen haben.
Ja bitte?
Ich wollte nur auf die Uhr gucken. Wir haben da noch was.
Wir müssen mit dem Kongress reden.
Der Herr Erdgeist wollte vorher noch den Tweet einer wichtigen Persönlichkeit zum Besten geben.
Das war ja das Weiße Haus und die haben vorgestern getwittert, dass sie total stolz darauf sind, dass noch vor fünf Jahren nur 6 Prozent der weltweiten Smartphones mit US-amerikanischen Betriebssystemen gelaufen sind. Damals gab es halt nicht so viel und inzwischen sind es 80 Prozent und die sind da total stolz drauf. Aber ich sehe es als Problem an, dass wir inzwischen in Europa mit Infrastruktur durch die Gegend laufen, die wir selbst nicht kontrollieren, die in den USA hergestellt und von dort kontrolliert und geupdatet wird.
Das wichtige ist, dass sie aus den USA geupdatet wird und dass es dort Gesetze gibt, die vorschreiben, dass Firmen in Zweifel Leuten Updates einspielen können müssen, die kompromittiert sind.
Ob das wohl auch für die neue Xbox One und die Kinect gilt?
Na aber.
Die die in 3D erfassen und aufnehmen damit.
Und die im Prinzip immer online ist. Die Xbox One Kinect ist letzte Woche erschienen, die neue Spielekonsole und am Anfang hatte Microsoft geplant, dass die Kamera, die zu dieser Spielekonsole gehört, die ganze Zeit ins Wohnzimmer reinguckt und auch lauscht, damit man sagen kann, Xbox startet das Spiel und es gab so einen heftigen Protest, dass das nicht mehr gemacht wurde. Ich war auf der Gamescom dieses Jahr und da hat so ein Entwickler von Xbox das vorgestellt. Ja, man kann es jetzt ausschalten, aber das will ja eh keiner. Aber ich lese tatsächlich erstaunlich viel, die das nicht mehr wollen. Aber diese Information von wegen, die Firma muss sie auch Zugriff gewähren, ist auch nicht ganz unspannend. Also ich bin tatsächlich, das war so ein Thema, das meanderte jetzt immer so ein bisschen durch, dieses Technik in unseren Haushalten, die aber gar nicht mehr unter unserer Kontrolle sind. Also da haben wir zum Beispiel die Spielekonsole, die immer online ist, da haben wir den Stromzettel, der immer online ist, da ist der Router, der uns nicht mehr gehört. Also ich glaube, das könnte möglicherweise ein Thema sein, das uns im nächsten Jahr das eine oder andere Mal beschäftigt. Und ich hoffe, ihr werdet euer Beruf berecht und erforscht die entsprechenden Geräte, damit man sieht.
Ich hab da schon Spatzen von den, von was pfeifen die eigentlich immer. Habe ich sie pfeifen hören, dass der CCC demnächst einmal die Smart Meter ein wenig intensiver noch unter die Lupe nehmen wird.
So, und dann gibt es ja diesen Kongress.
Genau, wir haben wie jedes Jahr zwischen dem 27. dem 30. unseren berühmten großen Kongress dieses Jahr, also Dezember, dieses Jahr zum 30. Mal ist der 30. C3, also der 30. Chaos Communication Congress. Und wir sind ja letztes Jahr schon mit dem Kongress nach Hamburg gezogen, weil wir in Berlin einfach schlicht kein Gebäude mehr gefunden haben, was so viel Platz hat.
Langsam Frank, langsam. Der Chaos Communication Congress, was ist das?
Was passiert da?
Also jetzt machen wir das 30 Jahre, müssen wir das noch erklären?
Ja, möglicherweise gibt es Leute, die noch nie dort waren, aber die denken das wäre vielleicht interessant, wenn man ihnen nur erzählen würde, was dort passiert. Also der Chaos Computer Club veranstaltet einmal im Jahr so eine Veranstaltung, wo einfach alle Nerds aufeinander kommen und...
Das ist wie Universität und Party gleichzeitig. Da versuchen wir in möglichst entspannter Atmosphäre nur schlaue Menschen zusammenzubringen, die sich gegenseitig Dinge erklären, sei es in einem organisierten Vortragsprogramm oder sei es abends bei der Bar oder sei es im Bällebad oder sei es in den sogenannten Assemblies. Das sind so einigermaßen spontan selbst organisierte Zusammentreffen von Leuten mit ähnlichen Interessen. Und da geht es eigentlich größtenteils um den Austausch von Wissen und mit den Kameras, die wir auf die Vorträge halten, versuchen wir auch so ein bisschen Bibliothek zu spielen, dieses Wissen für die Nachwelt und alle Interessierten auch für umsonst zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und da sind also haufenweise Leute, die das ganze Jahr nichts machen als an irgendeiner Sache rumzufrickeln und dann am Jahresende zu diesem Kongress zu fahren und zu sagen, hier guckt mal, was ich gebaut habe, das heißt die Kompetenz ist da geballt.
Zum Beispiel, aber es kommen auch Leute hin, die einfach nur einmal im Jahr ganz viele Bekannte sehen wollen. Also da ist ein ganz buntes Spektrum an Besuchern da, die wirklich den ganzen Jahr an einem Projekt hacken, die irgendwie was Neues herausgefunden haben, das zeigen wollen oder die einfach nur feiern wollen oder Leute treffen.
Also das alljährliche Hackerfamilien treffen.
Und in diesem Jahr wollen wir versuchen, ein wenig Leute heranzuführen, die sich üblicherweise nicht trauen. Und dazu wurde so ein Programm ins Leben gerufen, das heißt Chaosparten. Und ich glaube, da hat der Monoxid was vorbereitet.
In der Tat, sehr schön überlagend danke Herr Erdgeist. Gibt es Leute, die sich Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, weil man hört das immer so, Hacker treffen. Da sind halt diese, was war die Zahl vom letzten Jahr?
Wie viele Besucher gab es da?
7.000 Leute. Und man steht als möglicherweise neuer, also die Einladung ergeht immer vor dem Kongress, dass man sagt, ihr könnt wirklich alle kommen, ihr müsst keine Ahnung haben, ihr müsst nur neugierig sein. Aber man traut sich dann nicht so richtig. Man denkt so, aber die sind ja alle so und dann mögen mich... Und da haben sie jetzt Leute gedacht, hey, wir machen das anders. Wir wollen die Leute quasi ihnen eine Möglichkeit bieten, nichts zu wissen und trotzdem irgendwie sich zurechtzufinden. Und Fiona ist eine von den Leuten, die das mit organisiert. Und die hab ich halt gefragt, Chaospartin, was ist denn das eigentlich?
Die Chaospartin ist, dass es eine Idee, die jetzt Realität geworden ist. Und ja, was wir machen, ist einerseits Leute ermutigen, zum Kongress zu kommen, die bisher aus irgendwelchen Gründen vielleicht Angst davor hatten oder Berührungsängste. Und andererseits Leute, die jetzt zum ersten Mal dabei sind, begleiten und ihnen einen schönen Kongress ermöglichen.
Wie genau sieht das aus? Nehmt ihr sie an der Hand und zieht sie durch die Kongresshallen?
Am ersten Tag vielleicht, ja. Also einerseits, es ist eigentlich zwei Phasen, einerseits sind wir vor dem Kongress für die Leute da und stehen mit ihnen in E-Mail-Kontakt und sie können uns alle möglichen Fragen fragen. Und andererseits, die zweite Phase ist dann auf dem Kongress dort, nehmen wir sie tatsächlich am ersten Tag in Empfang und machen mit ihnen eine Führung über das Gelände und zeigen ihnen, wo es tolle Workshops gibt, wo sie Mate herbekommen und wo die Räume für die Talk sind und stellen auch mit ihnen zusammen ein Programm zusammen, entsprechend ihrer Interessen und einmal am Tag treffen wir uns alle, damit sich die Leute auch untereinander kennenlernen, die Chaos-Paten, Kinder sozusagen.
Bevor man sozusagen eine Paten in Anspruch nimmt, wie muss man erst überhaupt die Motivation verspüren, auf diesen Kongress zu fahren? Warum sollte man das tun?
Weil der Kongress supertoll ist und total interessant. Und ich meine, es gibt vielleicht bestimmte Gründe, warum die Leute das schon wissen, aber trotzdem Angst haben. Das können Hemmungen sein und auch da wollen wir ansetzen und sagen, ja, ihr müsst diese Ängste nicht haben. Auch wenn ihr jetzt keine krassen Hacker seid, seid ihr trotzdem herzlich willkommen. Und auch ihr könnt dort ganz, ganz viele tolle Sachen mitnehmen. Es ist spannend und ich glaube, es gibt ein sehr, sehr breit gefächertes Programm, das sehr spannend ist. Also von Vorträgen über Workshops und es gibt tolle Leute kennenzulernen und viele, viele tolle Sachen zu sehen.
Aber welche?
Ich persönlich freue mich unheimlich auf das Rohrpostsystem namens Silk Road, das gerade in Arbeit ist. Und ich finde, das ist so ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür, was man auch so vom Kongress als Idee mitnehmen kann. Da haben Leute eine völlig wahnsinnige Idee und setzen sie um.
Wie ist denn das, wenn ich jetzt als Teilnehmer auf den Kongress komme? Soll ich dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit kommen oder reicht ein Tag? Oder gibt es überhaupt eine Zeit, die besonders sinnvoll ist oder nicht?
Als Teilnehmer? Ich würde natürlich den Leuten, die kommen, ans Herz legen, alle drei Tage zu kommen, weil es einfach so viel zu sehen gibt. Seit letztem Jahr findet der Kongress in Hamburg statt, im CCH. Das ist ein riesiges Areal auf fünf Stockwerken. Da verläuft man sich auch am zweiten Tag noch, weil es einfach so viel zu sehen gibt. Es gibt auch an jedem Tag viele interessante Talks. Wenn man jetzt für einen Tag kommt, ist das natürlich auch in Ordnung. Aber ich würde schon drei Tage den Leuten ans Herz legen. Nicht zuletzt, da man sicherlich am ersten Tag tolle Leute kennenlernt und das die weiteren Tage auch noch machen kann.
Jetzt habt ihr ja gesagt, die macht die Chaos-Party, weil es da so eine Berührungsangst gibt. Woher kommt die?
Ich glaube, es ist bei jedem Kongress, der von so etwas wie einem Expertinnen-Experten-Kreis ausgerichtet wird, so dass man denkt, naja, das sind vielleicht Leute, die kennen sich ganz toll aus mit Computern. Mir geht es ja genauso, ich bin ja keine besonders tolle Programmiererin, geschweige denn eine Hackerin seit meinem ersten Lebensjahr. Deswegen denkt man vielleicht, man passt da nicht so ganz hin und man kann vielleicht den Talks nicht folgen. Aber ich glaube, das wäre bei jedem, das wäre auch bei einem linken Marx-Lesekreis so, dass man irgendwie Berührungsängste hätte. Und zum anderen, dass es natürlich auch einfach im Kongress ja drei Tage lang geht und wenn man noch niemanden kennt, da gibt es dann total viele Menschen. Man ist dann alleine, ist das vielleicht auch so ein bisschen einschüchtern. Und natürlich, das Chaos-Partner-System ist offen für alle, aber richtet sich ja auch an Frauen und Mädchen, wollen insbesondere die ermutigen, weil die vielleicht noch eine zusätzliche Angst haben, da sie eine Frau unter wenigen sind.
Ist das noch so?
Ja, es gibt da schon noch einen großen Unterschied, aber das ändert sich ja auch zunehmend.
Wie muss ich das dann machen, wenn ich da jetzt irgendwie mich betreuen lassen will?
Am besten ist es, wenn du einfach an unsere E-Mail-Liste schreibst, die ich gerade nicht im Kopf habe, aber wenn man auf die Event-Seite vom CCC geht, da steht dann die E-Mail und schreibst uns und sagst einfach, was dein Name ist, woher du kommst, was du so machst und was deine Interessen sind, damit wir dir einen Individual-Partner oder eine Patin zuordnen können. Die setzt sich dann mit dir in Kontakt nach ein paar Tagen und die betreut dich dann, bis du dann da bist.
Und wie ist die Reaktion bis jetzt darauf? Also sowohl einerseits innerhalb der Veranstalter, wissen die davon?
Ja, die wissen davon mittlerweile, hat sich auch schon rumgesprochen. Spätestens jetzt wissen sie davon.
Und wie finden die das? Gab es noch Reaktionen?
Ja, also wir haben das, wurde erfreulicherweise, wurde das auf dem Blog vom CCC Event geblockt, verblockt und darauf hingewiesen und die Reaktionen waren ausnahmslos großartig. Also sowohl von den Leuten aus dem CCC, die uns dabei ermutigten und uns viel Rückhalt geben und sagen, hey, es ist eine super Sache, dass ihr das macht. Und auch von Leuten, die uns sagen, dass sie sich das gerne schon früher gewünscht hätten. Und andererseits kriegen wir natürlich jede Menge Anfragen zurzeit. Also es flattern jeden Tag so ein paar Anfragen rein von Leuten, die so ganz verschiedene Gründe haben, warum sie bei uns mitmachen wollen und auch verschiedene Hintergründe haben, auch aus verschiedenen Ländern kommen. Und ja, da kommen mittlerweile, ich schätze schon, 30 Leute oder so, die uns geschrieben haben. Das werden immer mehr.
Darf man noch anfragen oder seid ihr schon voll?
Die fragen uns auf jeden Fall an. Wir haben glücklicherweise auch viele Leute, die sagen, sie möchten gerne uns unterstützen und auch Pate oder Paten werden. Und da sind auf jeden Fall noch Kapazitäten da.
Okay, muss ich jetzt irgendwelche Voraussetzungen mitbringen? Also ich denke jetzt so, okay, dieser Chaos-Kundress, das klingt interessant. Da wird sich sogar um neue Leute gekümmert. Muss ich irgendwas mitbringen außer ein Ticket?
Nein, eigentlich nichts außer ein Interesse daran. Und der Wille daran teilzunehmen. Ich glaube, wenn man einfach offen ist und auch die vielen Impressionen, die so auf einen einpassen, einfach zulässt und Interesse an dieser Community hat, an Computern, an Technik, daran etwas komplett Neues zu lernen, kann ja auch sein, dass du einen ganz anderen Hintergrund hast. Aber trotzdem gerne lernen möchte, was dort zu beigepracht wird. Und wenn du den Willen dazu hast und eine gesunde Portion Neugierde, dann bist du auf jeden Fall richtig.
Wir halten fest, ich traue mich nicht ist keine Ausrede mehr. Wenn ihr zum Chaos-Kongress gehen wollt, könnt ihr es gerne tun. Und wenn ihr wolltest, man euch zeigt, wie das ganze Ding funktioniert, könnt ihr euch an die Chaospartnern wenden.
Genau, die E-Mail-Adresse dazu ist chaospartnern.list.cccde. Nochmal chaospartnern.list.cccde.
Auf Show Notes wird das bestimmt alles mitgeschrieben. shownote.es Ein kleiner Service von Leuten aus dem Netz, die immer zur Sendung sozusagen eine kleine Textklärung machen. So, jetzt hier Chaos-Kongress.
Genau, wird total super. Wir haben irgendwie eine riesige Menge an Vorträgen. Also ich glaube, weit über 100 dieses Mal. Wir haben einen Saal mehr. Es wird natürlich das ganze Thema NSA, Abhöraffäre, wird eine große Rolle spielen im politischen Teil, aber auch im technischen Teil. Wir werden sehr viel darüber reden, wie wir uns als Gesellschaft verhalten zu diesen ganzen Dingen. Es wird auch jede Menge technische Talks geben, die echt voll der Knaller sind. Aber eben auch viele Sachen, die soll mal hands-on sind, also die mit Spaß im Spiel zu tun haben, mit Basteln, mit Making, mit Elektronik selber löten und so. Einfach auch so Sachen, worum man viel lernen kann.
Wir haben dieses Jahr für die verschiedenen Themen, die letztes Jahr noch von einem Content-Team, also von einem Team, das die Einreichungen an Vorträgen gesichtet hat, das haben wir dieses Jahr aufgeteilt, weil es einfach so viele geworden sind durch den zusätzlichen Raum, dass man das einfach so nicht mehr schafft. Und wir haben dadurch einen angenehmen Nebeneffekt, dass inzwischen auch nur noch Teams Vorträge ausgewählt haben, die sie wirklich hundertprozentig in diesem Thema drin stecken, was ziemlich cool ist, weil dadurch das Programm auch einfach unglaublich gewonnen hat. Und wir haben die Seitenstraße, die Fiona gerade schon erwähnt hat.
Die Seitenstraße ist so eines der Wahnsinnsprojekte, die wir da machen. Wir werden da aus zwei Kilometer Drainagerohr, und zwar dem ohne Löcher eine Rohrpost bauen, die im gesamten Kongressgebäude unterwegs ist. Es gab schon mal so ein Vorgängerprojekt davon, dass die Telekommunisten eine Künstlergruppe gemacht haben in Berlin zur Transmediale. Wir haben schon heftig experimentiert, durch so eine Drainagerohre Kapseln mit dem Staubsauger durchpusten oder durchsaugen. Da werden wir im Kongressgebäude ein physisches Paket vermitteltes System aufbauen, mit dem man sich allerhand Gegenstände durch die Gegend schießen kann. Es wird sicherlich ein großer Gaudi werden. Da suchen wir auch noch Leute, die da mithelfen beim Aufbauen. Denn wir sind so zwei Kilometer Rohr, sind so eine halbe Stunde spazieren entlang des Rohrs. Das wird ein großer Spaß.
Kann man euch da irgendwo sehen? Macht ihr Vorträge? Lauft ihr irgendwo rum, bastelt Sachen?
Ja, also ich werde wieder die Fnone News Show machen und die Security Nightmares und weiß nicht, die anderen beiden, frapsfoto ist.
Na, ich kümmere mich ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen und schau, dass jeder WLAN hat und Netz und ja, ich glaube da haben wir dieses Jahr mal wieder so einen Bandbreitenrekord und haben dieses Mal das erste Mal 100 Gigabit Außenanbindung, so die ganz neue Technik für den Endnutzer, für den Netzwerke wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Jahre alt, aber das erste Mal auf dem Kongress und das Nock baut da wieder ganz viel rum und mal schauen, ob es dieses Jahr überhaupt laufen wird.
So und dann haben wir, bevor der Kongress losgeht, wie gesagt, das Jahr, man kann mich da am 29.12. mit der Entertainment-Bühne übrigens sehen. Hab ich erfahren.
Du bist in Hamburg?
Ich bin in Hamburg.
Oh, ein Moderator zum Anfassen.
Aber vorher gibt es noch zwei kleinere Sachen, und zwar hier in Berlin.
Es gibt im Chaos Computer Club Berlin eine unregelmäßige Veranstaltung, die heißt Datengarten und die findet üblicherweise am Donnerstag, und zwar am ersten Donnerstag im Monat statt, immer praktisch nach dem Chaos Radio. Und auch am nächsten Donnerstag, wo sich das Projekt Chaos macht Schule Berlin vorstellt, also am Donnerstag, dem 5. Dezember um 20 Uhr im Chaos Computer Club in Berlin, das ist in der Marienstraße 11. Chaos macht Schule ist eine Gruppe von Leuten, die sich im gesamten Bundesgebiet auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, in Schulen zu gehen, dort Schülern, Eltern und Lehrern gleichermaßen so wenig Netzkompetenz zu vermitteln, denen zu zeigen, was man benutzen soll, welche Techniken man besser vermeiden soll, wie soziale Mechanismen im Internet funktionieren, wie die Gefahren lauern, wie Mobbing funktioniert, was man als Eltern auch achten sollte, was die Kinder an Software benutzen, welche Webseiten sie angucken. Also so was ist ein mir persönlich am Herzen liegendes Projekt, weil dort wirklich Leute sich gefunden haben und freiwillig diesen Bildungsauftrag, den der Chaos Computer Club sich auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, dann dort im Kleinen immer wieder umsetzen, um wirklich was zu bewegen. Und dieses Projekt in der Stelle Berlin stellt sich da nächsten Donnerstag vor, sucht da noch weitere Mitstreiter. Und wer Interesse daran hat, entweder selber in Schulen zu gehen oder wer sich einfach nur mal über den Stand des Themas informieren möchte, der ist da eingeladen, am nächsten Donnerstag vorbeizukommen.
So, dann haben wir am Donnerstag danach noch etwas mit Weltraum, was ja wunderbar zum letzten Chaos Radio passt.
Genau, da geht es um einen Dosen-Satelliten, also um so einen Satelliten im Selbstbau. Und da wird ein jährlicher Wettbewerb ausgeschrieben, der heißt CanSat und der findet in Bremen statt. Und ein paar Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Clubs wollen dabei mal schauen, ob der CCC selber so einen Satelliten vielleicht lauschen kann oder bei der Programmierung helfen, eventuell für die kleinen Satelliten anderer Gruppen noch zusätzliche Sensorik herstellen, vielleicht Arduino-Projekte damit aushelfen. Und genau, das ist am 12. Dezember in der Marienstraße 11, um 19 Uhr geht es dann los. Und auch dort sind alle Weltraumbegeisterten, die sich vielleicht vom letzten Chaos Radio haben anfixen lassen, eingeladen dort den Stand der Cans-Head-Forschung zu verfolgen.
Also, auf dem Computer oder in den Weltraum, all das geht im Chaos Computer Club, der sich für dieses Jahr dann hier von Fritz verabschiedet. Erdgeist, Nibbler, Fraps, Frank, vielen Dank fürs dabei sein. Und das Chaos Radio gibt es dann wahrscheinlich Ende Januar wieder. Für dieses Jahr ist es wie gesagt vorbei. Jetzt kommt gleich Flo Heiler und wird euch mit Punk-Musik bewerfen, damit euch die Ohren mal so richtig schön freigeblasen werden. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich bin raus und habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Verbeckert immer schön eure Verschlüsselung und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Tschüss!
Und don't forget I'm in your extended network.